anyone who has played even a small
amount of Chess especially online is
familiar with the concept of an opening
trap we've all fallen for one at some
point or another in many cases a failed
opening trap will leave you with a
terrible position but not always we've
compiled 10 opening traps that are not
only guaranteed to work but if your
opponent doesn't fall for them exactly
you'll still have a decent position
number one Noah Arc this trap occurs in
the ruy Lopez opening and the goal is to
trap the opponent's light squared Bishop
after some Theory the position can
arrive here after black plays Knight
takes D4 after an exchange of knights
White's Queen is aiming to win back a
sacrificed Pawn this is the beginning of
the Trap if you are fortunate enough for
your opponent to play Queen takes D4 the
following sequence is available C5 Queen
D5 Bishop E6 stopping the Checkmate
threat and allowing The Rook to be
protected Queen C6 six check Bishop D7
Queen D5
C4 now the bishop is finally trapped but
wait what if white does not fall for the
Trap and take the poisoned Pawn white
has other good options such as Bishop D5
C3 A4 but all lead to a roughly equal
position which is great for black out of
the opening number two leg almate this
opening trap if your opponent cooperates
can lead to one of the most beautiful
and famous checkmates in chess named
after s deal it dates back all the way
to the 18th century it occurs in an
Italian game and in this position we
play Knight C3 black might play Bishop
G4 pinning the Knight to White's Queen
and we can play H3 forcing black to make
a decision about the light squared
Bishop if they retreat with Bishop H5
this allows the brilliant Knight takes
E5 where a free Queen is offered if
black takes the bait and grabs the queen
can you spot the famous mate in
two that's right Bishop takes F7 King E7
which is forced Knight D5 mate so if our
opponent does not take the queen bait is
this a dubious position not at all
Black's best response is Knight takes E5
allowing white to win the light squared
Bishop with Queen takes H5 and after
black takes the bishop on C4 white can
win the piece right back with a queen
check on B5 picking up the Knight on the
following turn no matter what Black's
response is white is up a pawn with
control of the center a great place to
be out of the opening number three the
Cambridge Springs trap this trap arises
out of a popular line in the Queen's
Gambit declined in this position white
might take the pawn with C takes D5
black responds with e takes D5 and white
might be tempted to take the pawn on D5
with the Knight taking advantage of the
fact that the Knight defending it on F6
is pinned to the queen well black can
disregard this pin and take on D5 anyway
can you spot Black's best continuation
after white takes the queen on
d8 it's the only check in the position
Bishop B4 check the idea becomes
painfully clear to white here the only
legal move is to block with the queen
after Bishop takes D2 King takes D2
black can scoop up the bishop on d8 and
is simply up a piece if your opponent
doesn't take the poison pond with Knight
takes D5 and plays E3 instead providing
a valuable Escape Square for the king
black can play the straightforward C6
leading to a roughly equal
position number four the Lasker trap the
Lasker trap is named after the second
world champion Emanuel Lasker and it
happens in the Albin counter Gambit
against White's Queen's Gambit shown
here after d takes E5 D4 white can't
develop the Knight to C3 and they might
play the seemingly innocuous E3 which is
in fact a serious mistake after Bishop
B4 check White's best response is to
block with their Bishop on D2 which is
where the Trap begins black can leave
their Bishop hanging on B4 and take the
pawn on E3 if white takes this free
Bishop black has to follow up e takes F2
check and since at this point the king
is needed to defend the queen on D1 it
must maintain contact with King E2 Can
you spot Black's only winning move here
here that's right it's a rare under
promotion F takes G1 equals Knight check
this is the only way to take the Knight
on G1 with Tempo coming in the form of a
check on the king if the pawn is
promoted to a queen white can trade
Queens on d8 with tempo as well pick up
the promoted Queen on G1 and be left
with an even material game with black
having no attack another convenient
aspect of this under promotion is that
white can't even take the Knight if they
do black has Bishop G4 check skewering
the king and queen if we go all the way
back to D takes E3 and white does not
take the bishop on G4 but plays F takes
E3 instead black enjoys a great position
after Queen H4 check G3 Queen E4
attacking The Rook on H1 and the pawn on
E3 since White's Bishop can't defend it
on account of the pin number five the
reubenstein Trap this one is named after
polish Grandmaster Akiba Rubenstein who
is considered to have been one of the
greatest players to never have become
World chess champion that said it's
interesting to note that this trap is
named after him because he fell into it
twice it can happen in the Queen's
Gambit declined though it requires a lot
of cooperation from your opponent white
has just played their 11th move but
still this exact position has occurred
hundreds of times in Master Level play
including this game between alakin and
Rubenstein
here Rubenstein went for Knight E4 and
alakin followed up with Bishop F4 black
then played F5 trying to solidify the
Knight on e4 at this point white has the
tricky Knight takes D5 if black is
greedy and takes it with C takes D5 Can
you spot White's winning move in this
position yes Bishop C7 and the black
queen is trapped in rubenstein's game he
saw this and did not play C takes D5 but
rather the best try for black with
Bishop D6 a free Center Pawn was enough
for alakin to gain and maintain an
advantage winning the game in the
end number six the Siberian trap this
trap can happen in the Smith Mora Gambit
and other openings more often in Blitz
and across all playing levels after
white has sacrificed a pawn for
initiative both sides develop normally
to get to this position here black has
the great move Knight G4 starting
starting to add pressure to the H2
Square white might get an inflated sense
of safety since the Knight on F3
protects against mate so they play H3
attempting to kick the Knight on G4 This
falls right into the Trap can you see
why if you spotted Knight D4 well done
black is happy to leave the G4 Knight
hanging as it has an attack on the queen
and if white takes the Knight with
Knight takes D4 black is now free to
Checkmate on H2 with the queen in fact
White's best response is to take the
Knight on G4 getting two pieces for the
queen but still resulting in a lost
position if white doesn't play The
crucial H3 mistake playing instead for
instance Knight B5 to attack the queen
and defend D4 with another piece black
can move the queen back to B8 and enjoy
a pleasant position while up a pawn
number s the fjara witch trap this
sneaky trap comes out of the Budapest
Gambit opening black ends up up
sacrificing two minor pieces in order to
win the White Queen here white will very
likely play D takes E4 and after Knight
E4 Knight F3 D6 e takes D6 Bishop takes
D6 white might play G3 a reasonable
looking move preparing to fian ketto the
bishop this is in fact a grave error can
you see
why that's right black has the resource
Knight takes F2 the idea behind this is
if white recaptures on F2 black has the
discovered attack Bishop G3 check on the
next turn allowing the black queen to
capture the White Queen on D1 if white
doesn't make the mistake of G3 instead
playing the engine's best move Knight B
D2 black can respond with Bishop F5
giving a roughly equal position where
black has sacrificed a pawn for a lead
in development number eight the
Blackburn Shilling trap in this trap
black violates all the basic opening
principles in order to cat catch white
off guard at first it looks like black
is playing careless moves but after
Queen takes G2 you can see who is really
in trouble this trap comes out of a
variation of the Italian game or Joko
piano after the slightly dubious Knight
D4 from black white can get greedy and
take the pawn on E5 leading to this
position black can now play Queen G5 and
if White's greed continues they will
play Knight takes F7 forking Black's
Queen and Rook as mentioned earlier
Queen takes G2 is the continuation and
White's Rook is now under attack so they
will quite likely be tempted to play
Rook F1 black then plays Queen takes E4
and white only has two legal moves to
block with the queen or Bishop if the
queen blocks then black can take the
queen with the Knight for a significant
material advantage and if the bishop
blocks black has an even quicker path to
Victory can you see what it
is a very quick path to to Victory
indeed with the beautiful Knight F3
Checkmate going back to Black's Queen G5
move even if white doesn't play the
critical mistake of Knight takes F7 but
rather checks the king with Bishop takes
F7 check black is still in good shape
after sidest stepping with King d8 in
this case white has to Castle to avoid
the threat of Queen takes G2 and black
can pick up the free Knight on E5 giving
up two pawns and castling rights in
exchange for a full piece number nine
smother mate in The Budapest Gambit
here's another trap that stems from The
Budapest Gambit after the Gambit is
played Mainline Theory can arrive at
this position black can disregard the
hanging bishop and play Knight G takes
E5 if white gets greedy and takes the
bishop on B4 right away can you spot
Black's immediate
win that's right black has smothered
mate with Knight D3 Checkmate if they
trade on E5 Knight takes E5 Knight takes
E5
then take the bishop black still has
smothered mate if white happens to see
the smothered mate threat they can play
the solid E3 instead of a takes B4 and
black can trade off the dark squared
Bishop with Bishop takes D2 here the
engine says the position is roughly
equal number 10 the fishing pole trap
the concept of the fishing pole can come
out of many variations of the ruy Lopez
opening some fishing poles work and some
don't after this common line of the ruy
Lopez the trap begins with the simple
Bishop G4 pinning the Knight on F3 white
will likely respond with H3 with the
intention of kicking the bishop and the
engine agrees with this move black of
course doesn't want to move the same
piece twice in succession which is where
the ingenious H5 comes in leaving the
bishop hanging if white can't resist the
free Bishop they'll play H takes G4
taking the bait of the fishing pole
Black's response of H takes G4 right
back has a two-fold purpose it attacks
the Knight on F3 and opens up the H file
for an attack if white tries to save the
Knight with Knight takes E5 can you see
Black's forced mating sequence that's
right it starts with queen H4 the threat
down the H file is now obvious and white
attempts to give an escape Square to the
king with F3 or F4 this idea is shut
right down with G3 with no way to stop
mate on H2 or H1 if white realizes they
can't move the Knight on F3 they might
play something like D3 but black is
still decidedly better with no rush to
take the Knight as it can't move from
that square
[Music]
anyway